i want you know ambition and a guy that
we can like build a foundation together
they'd be like whoa whoa whoa too much
commitment too scary i mean have you
ever been on like a terrible date like
we love hearing bad dating what was the
one bad dating oh what do you mean i met
up with this oh here we go what the [ __ ]
is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone we just become best friends
yup am i sweating in this oh yes yeah
[ __ ] okay arms down that's what i hate
about gray shirts
i don't know i thought it would be fine
but we're two minutes into the show
we've already gotten one armpit stain
we're spitzing
there we go finally you're catching on
thank you thank you thank you hello
everybody and welcome back to another
episode of the unwaxed podcast with your
favorite sisters sophia and sistine rose
stallone we went to disneyland recently
and i can feel my throat
still
i don't know why you said it like that
a sword i don't know if you guys can
hear this from screaming so loud and i
feel like it was when we went on the new
guardians of the galaxy right that that
was the moment i knew
my voice would be raspy for you all the
time i've always had really mixed
feelings about disneyland it's sort of
one of those things
like squid games like things in pop
culture like bridgerton where big
amounts of people are like this is
amazing so then everyone sort of follows
being like this is amazing
that's how i feel about disneyland it's
supposed to be the happiest place on
earth yet i feel like a little sad girl
when i'm there i don't understand why
you know why it's because when we're
younger i think the whole aesthetic of
the rides and the the the costume
characters and the aesthetics you're
just like oh my god this is a child's
dream yeah but then as you get older
you're like this is all one like kind of
weird two everyone is smelly i'm sorry
not everyone yes everyone is dressed in
what what did this who was it he was
talking about how everyone's wearing
crocs like so many no shade on crocs but
like everyone was wearing crocs
i spent about two days before going on
disneyland food tick tock
so i was like okay i know exactly what
we're gonna get i know the best rated
things
i was pretty disappointed in the food
yeah so was i there was a few things
here and there i was like okay i can see
it but i mean who doesn't love a deep
fried pretzel cinnamon
jalapeno dipped in cheese sauce actually
this is kind of funny so sophia was on a
mission during disneyland to find this
jalapeno
stuffed with cream trees pretzel right
yeah and that's the only thing we go to
like two stands both sold out and she is
now pissed because she this is all she
wanted like did i get it too i was like
i want the pretzel as well
so we were running around just trying to
find something we like not a big corn
dog gal there was just a lot of stuff we
didn't like so we walk into this weird
looks like western
like the saloon it looks like a saloon
right one of those weird western saloons
from an old timey movie
and um
we're like okay cool chicken fingers and
we managed to find the only salad in
disneyland which by the way
is so gross that we would even get a
salad it was just lettuce and ranch and
deep fried chicken all over top and lots
lots of rice you guys are like why would
you go to disneyland to get a salad
that's totally fair because why would we
go to disneyland i don't know we're
hoping just to be healthy a little bit
because we had three margaritas pre we
did do that so we're like yeah let's
soak it up with lettuce
very dumb but anyway so we're sitting
in the saloon and we're just trying to
scarf down the meal really fast to get
back to our friends and go back on the
rides and all of a sudden this guy comes
out like he's in an old-timey barber
shop quartet and he starts playing like
ding-ding-ding
let me explain
really quick so when you walk in it's
kind of a circular place and there's a
stage and like an auditorium the
auditorium on this this floor where
you're supposed to sit or tables where
you're eating and on the left side or
right side it was like the way you order
and this guy comes out yeah it looks
like uh from like mary poppins like pop
up
in a quartet barbershop quartet yeah but
it was just him on stage with this one
piano and he's like happy birthday and
sophia like this is our version of hell
yeah i said if i had to be put anywhere
forever and ever on the time loop maybe
with this guy happy birthday
[Laughter]
i've been like hitting my head rattling
on california screaming like okay so i
honestly left feeling like i just did
the longest marathon of my life
i was so exhausted as if i worked
extremely hard but i have to say for me
i you don't like i like disneyland like
i actually do see why people like it
because i it does bring back some
nostalgic things also i love roller
coasters and i think it's fun when you
go on like pirates of caribbean and it
smells the same as it did when you're
like although it was closed that was
closed that may mean really disneyland
i'll see you in the indiana jones i can
repeat that video that plays on repeat
for like eight hours a day oh my god you
know it's just fun so we went there but
then we also had this debate yesterday
just to switch up topics um system went
on pinterest recently and we're talking
about how she officially thinks
pinterest is 10 times better than
instagram it is
you know what i've always been
embarrassed to say this because
pinterest is what you did in middle
school when they gave you an ipad
instead of a textbook and that's all you
do during class i think you do it either
when you're in middle school or you're
about to get married at 30. or there's
not like a mom looking for a healthy
recipe yeah you're not in your 20s and
like really
let me tell you the algorithm is genius
the feed phenomenal it really is
actually it is so good instagram is so
boring now with all these updates i feel
like no one posts interesting stuff then
again i only follow like cat meme
accounts so that's not that exciting it
is it's like a cleaner version of tumblr
because when you used to follow tumblr
we loved looking at those photos and
this is like a tumblr tumblr tumblr is a
little kinky well yeah that slide really
i'm not gonna lie
she gets flustered
when i um
first joined up oh yeah when i first
joined uh tumblr i was like i'm gonna
make a really artsy fashion so sexy dog
so dark so emo basically exactly what
kylie jenner's was when she was doing it
yeah it was like king kylie that was
like the coolest thing ever to me
and um as i follow some obscure accounts
some obscure photos would
go with said accounts like
pretty sexual gifts yeah and photos it's
just not even that it'd be like a veiny
hand like clutching up
like a blanket and you're my intro to
middle school
no like my intro to anything
sexual was
gifts
like it would just be like a man like
grabbing a woman's thigh with the skirt
and it would just be looping and i'm
like wow like
and i would watch it like 30 times wow
because i just first of all like porn
not a thing for me i was just like
that's too scary that's too much but
tumblr gifts
they still hit today like the lip
fighting [ __ ] where they would oh my god
oh my god like a girl just like kissing
enough i'm like i can't wait to get
older
all of a sudden but i actually
completely agree i've been on tumblr uh
no
pinterest a lot more now and i just
think i like the fact that it's
curated to me for the things i like
which are food things or
wedding in spongebob
you have so much weddings but i just
like the aesthetic of weddings it's not
that i want to get married but i think
it's so pretty when they're by a beach
or whatever in dresses i should i don't
know maybe i should have been on wedding
planner but uh
and i don't know instagram is getting
boring and i feel like i just don't want
to see someone else's face again and
it's just i got it yeah it's getting old
i'm i'm realizing as i'm living alone
how obsessed i'm getting with certain
things that are unhealthy like pinterest
i spend probably
two hours of my screen time on it a day
and you're also getting unhealthily
obsessed with summer house
dude okay so i had to stop watching
vanderpump rules i'm a die hard fan she
watched it like sit now six times in a
row from season one to season nine or
something crazy like that five five
times five sophia i'm not that crazy
each episode or season is how many
episodes like 25 yeah so okay it's like
a session i realized it was a problem
when scenes were coming up and i was
reciting it with them yeah like i knew
the dialogue which was unscripted so
well yeah i said this is alarming so i
started dabbling into summer house
because i'm a big fan
of these two girls that have a podcast
called giggly squad hannah and paige and
they're on summer house and let me tell
you this [ __ ] slaps yeah nice
it's so good yeah i'm already done with
two seasons wow and it's been a week
yeah that's true not great i know we got
into winter house and that's when i
think your transition to summer house
happened and i've been watching once
again i think i talked about before
temptation island the
dumbest show to join on if you're a
couple no boy island might be one no no
no i'm talking if you're in a
relationship
and you want your relationship to end
you go on an island where you separate
the couple who've been dating for seven
years and put them in a house with girls
that are trying to take your money
turned on girls and 20 turned on guys
like actively hitting on your person and
they get to watch what their significant
other is doing so of course oh my god of
course i'm like do you remember season
four
this was
heartbreaking this one guy had a
threesome with two girls that were not
his girlfriend yeah and his girlfriend
had to watch the threesome on an ipad
and they were there for five years
that was wild so that's my favorite show
ever what would what would you do um
what would i do
i would say to
what's his name who's the host uh
mark
okay it's uh oh my god it's mark i think
his name is mark wahlberg it isn't
actually it is uh i would tell mark it
would be like mark
marky mark like my promise ring
toss it and then i'd have a great rest
of the summer so you know what i would
do
i would hire
a trained monkey right
because i'm not allowed to go to their
house don't shake your head hear me out
i'm not allowed to go to the boys house
so i'd hire a trained monkey
as he's sitting by the pool perhaps
tanning on the beach with his new girls
i'd have the monkey go up the palm tree
with the little mini saw
and saw a coconut off hits him on the
head
no one will ever tie back to me
sister
that's pretty smart that you have blood
on your hands now no the monkey does the
monkey can't talk like do you realize
how full proof this plan is that's just
the dumbest thing i also have remember
my other murder technique no oh that
well everyone knows about the frozen
icicle and you stab them and then ice
cold melts
i thought i was so creative for that did
you know that one
it's a yeah exactly it's a riddle yes
she said it's a riddle you know i hate
when i do that when i hear something and
take credit for it actually like someone
didn't already know i knew the high
school trick before everyone i tried
this one's a first you have to admit
yeah
that monkey one yeah
but you know what i feel like people
when obviously when they go on those
shows their relationship is starting to
go down anyways but why would you want
it to
tank like that like i mean it's no they
do it people
no they do it because they want to see
if this person is the one they really
want to be yeah but then do that in
normal life you don't do it sophia maybe
the show maybe they also just want to be
reality famous yeah that's probably why
they're doing it that's true i actually
got a really funny phone call from dad
yesterday
and he had this like tissue up to his
mouth and i was like what's wrong with
you like are you okay
and he goes sistine you won't even
believe it so i'm on set and i'm
shooting the scene and this scene is my
dream i'm eating a bowl of ice cream so
he goes i get to eat like five bowls of
ice cream because i'm just doing take
after take and he goes after the second
take
i chomp down on my bottom lip and it
starts bleeding and he goes granted the
camera angle can't see the blood coming
out of my mouth but i can see it going
in my vanilla ice cream and he goes
do you know how gross it is to eat blood
that's on your ice cream because it was
tasting all minerally it's so nasty so
nasty and he goes and you know what
happens when you bite the first time you
bite it a second time and he was like it
was a disaster and then the people that
were apparently shooting the scene with
him were like what's going on with your
face dude like he was bloody is he like
did he have to have stitches or
something no not bad that's pretty
brutal
it's pretty brutal i mean like you can't
get that excited about ice cream i do i
have a card in the other night i'm
totally i'm not even lying what's your
flavor
um it's milk and cookies by ben and
jerry's
you would or half baked i actually used
to play this game with people out of
just me and i'd describe their
personality as a carton of ice cream and
it really ticks some people off like if
you call someone pistachio
that's an insult oh you call them a
pistachio ice cream yeah i feel like
vanilla is pretty bad too no no no
that's like really no what's really bad
is like a snow cone
like that's bad that is pretty bad so to
wrap up this intro we are so excited to
introduce the girl that i have been
actually seeing all over tik tok
recently her name is ella she is a
sports illustrated curvy model who is so
confident so honest so beautiful i i
mean
i have seen her on all these other uh
podcasts and she's very well spoken and
fun yeah and i think she's gonna i've
never met her i'm really excited to take
a few tips from her because lord knows i
need some confidence i think we're all
going to vibe very well so stay tuned
and you're going to be ella yay
[Music]
everyone spring has sprung and you and
your man's lawn needs mowing it is that
time of year we all know it it's spring
cleaning and i am not talking about your
cluttered closet the global leaders in
the below waist grooming have the best
tools for the perfect spring clean
manscaped has the full package for your
household needs for spring cleaning this
year the performance package 4.0 is the
only tool you need to keep the lawn
smooth and smelling fresh to start off
your spring cleaning use the manscaped
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the best product
to get the most precise shave to keep
both your hedges clean and smooth did we
mention sofia that it's also waterproof
not only that sustained it's also
equipped with led lights so you know
exactly what's going on down there it's
so good you guys this tool that you'll
want to buy it for yourself
exactly the same one after you see how
smooth he is down there it's gonna be
like a party in your shower
and you can also help him smell the
roses with the nose and ear hair trimmer
provide proprietary skin safe technology
which helps prevent nicks snags and tugs
and all of the little delicate handles i
mean there's nothing more than
a dirty nose so after that whole thing
is cleared up you'll want to get rid of
that foul pull smell with the crack
preserver and crop reviver ping you the
crop preserver you guys remember is an
anti-chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer the crop reviver is a
spray-on toner for the balls and these
formulations seriously will leave him
smearing like fresh spring flowers
finish off his grooming routine with the
plow 2.0 the perfect razor for the
finest shave on his face yes not his
balls this time this razor seriously is
a game changer on your legs you'll have
to buy enough for the both of you oh my
god what doesn't it do so you guys just
remember this the start of the spring
also marks the start of testicular
cancer awareness month in april manscape
has partnered up with the testicular
cancer society to bring awareness to
testicular cancer men's health and early
cancer detection manscaped is committed
to raising awareness for the most common
form of cancer in men aged 15 to 35
giving support for fighters survivors
and families impacted by testicular
cancer as part of their we save balls
initiative
okay guys so if you're interested in
this get 20 off plus free shipping using
the code unwaxed manscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code
unwaxed at manscape.com out with the old
grooming habits and in with the new
mansky you're gonna look like a spring
chicken
[Music]
her instagram bio reads ceo of
confidence so we are in for a treat this
gorgeous girl is a model entrepreneur
social media influencer tick tock
creator and not only that
she is a sports illustrated model she's
beautiful she's hilarious she's honest
and she has it all this is ella helicos
yay ella studio audience
hello okay thank you crowd thank you
guys
a ceo yeah of course
yes ceo of confidence how do i apply for
a job to be under your position i'm dead
um you know the name just kind of came
to me because i was just preaching
confidence all the time and i was like
you know what yeah ceo of confidence i
like that i have a little twist to it um
do they respond to you for saying that
dude like why are you calling yourself
ceo of confidence or do they ask you
questions about confidence
i think it's because i was getting so
many questions on it and like how are
you confident how are you doing i'm like
you know what i could be a coach now
like ceo of confidence so that's kind of
what would you consider yourself a
little bit of a social media confidence
coach in a way for sure and i want to
like lean towards that way to
like help more like one-on-one with
helping girls with that right um because
it's something that i preach and i feel
like i embody but then like to actually
like teach others and like help an
audience is like another thing did you
learn that from maybe hearing someone
else uh that you looked up to and you're
like oh i really like what they're
talking about i want to share my twist
on that knowledge or was it something
that came inherently to you
um something that kind of just like came
for me i think later in life but i was
like super insecure growing up so it's
not something that like i always had
right right um but then just seeing
other like curve and plus size models
like do what they do right ashley graham
i was just so inspired by it all that i
was like
okay it clicked for me and now i feel
confident and like i want to share this
like light with others so right kind of
passing on what do you define as
confidence like because i feel like some
people can say it's the way they wear
their clothes or the way they act or
when they talk like how did you like
what makes you confident like how do you
act confident yeah i would say it's just
like knowing your worth and knowing that
like you are enough and i know it sounds
so freaking cliche but like
you literally are i'm like it's more
about like for me like my confidence
came more from like internal like i
actually like got bigger like physically
it's like the biggest i've ever been but
like the most confident i've ever been
and i think it was like a shift in my
mindset of like why am i like holding
myself back why am i not letting myself
live or like going on vacation or like
wearing the bikini so it was like a
mindset shift you know
i feel that way too because i think that
a lot of things like honestly having
this podcast for me like when i know i'm
confident it's the way i'm talking and
the way i'm not filtering myself or
looking at people for approval right
really just honing it on this is what
i'm saying this is what i'm doing and
i'm not gonna like let anyone judge me
on that and i also realized how much
energy i was putting into like worrying
about everyone else and like what they
thought about me i'm like i feel that
life sucks i feel like until you
actually gain that confidence and takes
a long time like i don't know if you do
things
daily to like enforce that confidence
because i feel like it is like a
learning thing until it becomes natural
totally like a habit yeah did you do any
like habits yeah just like affirmations
honestly and i think it was more of like
less habits and more of just being like
fed up like just like tired of feeling
tired right and like it's literally
draining like and people so relate to
this yeah like
it's exhausting it's like you just want
to feel free you don't want to like have
to worry or like overthink it and so
i mean with that comes like practice and
habits and every day i still work on it
like not every day i feel like super
confident totally um but yeah i would
say it's more of like a habit of the
mindset you know do you believe in um
when people say like oh fake it till you
make it when it comes to confidence
because i've been told that a lot and
i'm like okay yeah you're right i'm
gonna fake it till i make it but if i
really break it down like
it does it's not natural and it's not
how i really feel inside so i'm like i'm
genuinely just putting on a show again
to appease other people
you know what i mean so like do you
sometimes i mean it's not hard to be
confident all the time but do you
sometimes
force it even though it's like you're
not having a good day or you want to
share with your followers like oh i feel
confident or sometimes are you like you
know what today is not my day and like i
don't feel that great right i think with
the fake it till you make it i genuinely
think like i've never heard that side
that's a good point like it's basically
putting on a show yeah otherwise it
could be like
you're faking it but then like if you
look in a mirror and tell yourself like
you're a bad [ __ ] and like can i cuss
on this yeah
oh my god please uh we're called unwaxed
okay great just checking
um but like yeah just like hyping
yourself in the mirror every day like
even if you don't really believe it in
that moment like you're gonna start
believing right like so it almost like
that's also like a habit that can shift
it do i say it's good to be like
ingenuine and like not real with it no
but like if that helps you get to a
point of confidence then i say do it
totally and like yeah doing the things
that you know will make you more
confident i know for me if like i wake
up in the morning no i don't feel like
the most confident with no makeup but
i'm like if i put my outfit on my hair
on my makeup i feel great and it's just
going to shift you know your energy of
the day totally is there something that
you do all the time that you're like i
feel the most confident when i do this
um honestly like just positive self-talk
like
and definitely hanging around people
that are confident helps a lot because
if someone's super insecure around you
like granted like that's not a
reflection of you and like don't take on
other people's like whatever
insecurities but it's really good it
really does affect you like you feel the
energy of someone that's like oh i feel
so ugly today it's like okay well [ __ ]
do i look ugly then like you know i
didn't even put that in perspective yeah
having the confident people around you
because you can be confident in yourself
but if people aren't like hyping you up
with you and like truly meaning yeah not
saying like oh that outfit doesn't look
good on you or oh yeah you look pretty
like totally we have a bad habit of say
if someone
is uh self-deprecating oh like my hair
looks like [ __ ] so fee and i have such a
bad habit of trying to make them feel
better so being like you know what my
skin is breaking out so bad too and like
yeah oily floors right now and then all
of a sudden i'm like wait dude do i have
i'm like why did i say that my face
looks ugly when i'm like i don't feel
like i'm like ugly right so
yeah what if you're
a friend or a sibling or like you're in
a relationship and that person is just
super insecure like what would you tell
them to sort of get them out of that i
would just like allow for a grace period
of like feeling like [ __ ] like that's
normal it happens like allow that like
few minutes to like bash yourself if you
need to get it off your chest how you
feel and then like snap yourself back
into it and like
i like if someone wants to like talk
about how i'm not like stop doing that
that's triggering or like you know what
i'm just like okay i get you but yeah it
also makes that person a little
uncomfortable too because like what you
said like i feel like you know in a
sense misery likes company so someone's
literally miserable about themselves you
feel like you kind of need to match
their energy right so then it's like
awkward because then it pulls you down
but if you allow them to get down um
embrace that maybe add like a few things
about what you think like you know
actually the other day i was like oh my
period i felt like [ __ ] like you know
what no like we're bad [ __ ] let's go
like they look cute like and then snap
it back in
it's good to have that like a little
morning period for yourself because i do
feel like people are like well if i'm
not feeling it all the time that i'm not
feeling it at all or like i i don't feel
like this point if because people look
at people that are confident they're
like it's so easy for them they have it
all it comes so naturally right
i don't feel great all the time this
morning i was like oh i feel bloated i
feel this i feel that but i'm like okay
i'm gonna do my hair makeup i'm gonna
feel good about it and i'm not gonna let
other people like indicate or dictate
like how i'm feeling yeah that's how my
mom she always tells us like you're
allowed to be sad you're allowed to you
know feel bad for yourself you're
allowed to be in that hole but don't
stay in there too long because like when
you continue that cycle it's really hard
to get out of it yeah being confident
like i because we love talking about
dating and love like do you have
statings
harder because like sometimes guys are
very intimidated by confidence and i
understand a very loud time as you can
tell we don't stop talking so sometimes
it's like hindered it and sometimes
we'll find the guys like love that like
right like dude
that's interesting because i would say
in my overall life i'm super confident
but with dating i'm not really yeah what
areas are you not confident i don't even
know like now let's get down to therapy
i don't even
i like i can't even put a t on it but
like
i think like when i'm with my friends or
like on social media like i'm so
confident feel great but when it comes
to dating i'm like
i don't know if it's because of my body
or like i'm overthinking it or like
i i really don't know what it is but
like i come off confident when i walk
into a bar so maybe yeah they are
intimidated to like come up and talk to
me or whatever
but like when it comes to actual dating
i've never had a solid relationship in
my life that like makes me feel good
about it you know what i mean so
i've never had like what a good example
even like my parents being divorced like
i've never had a solid example of like
true love
so like i feel like when it comes to
dating i haven't been like solid yeah
that's actually interesting because i
kind of feel the same way i get that
because when i'm with my friends i'm
like i can be myself they love it they
match each other's energy yeah i went up
with a guy i'm like almost filtering
myself i'm like are they judging me
right you're so being weird
how they're viewing you but we often
forget like they're probably thinking
the same thing about themselves right
and i also just think that there's such
an interesting dating culture especially
living in la and being on these dating
apps and all you see are like the best
photos of everyone looking flawless and
perfect and
i think there is some
messed up beauty standard that
guys have also put into
females heads at times being like this
is a ideal image of what you should look
like right and i know sometimes when i'm
like going on a date or
i'm meeting up with a guy it's like i
still even
don't feel like
i'm ever like enough and i totally
understand where you're coming from when
it when you said like
it's hard when you haven't
been through it and you don't know
like how
you deserve to be treated right i've
been in love before
oh um i
thought i was but like that was such a
toxic version of love but like i
definitely thought i was
at the time how did you not realize you
were
um i think just like dating other guys
and realizing like oh that wasn't normal
or like i was grudged like i was dating
an older guy that like whatever and like
i definitely
like that was grooming that wasn't real
like did like were those feelings real
yes but like true deep like real love i
don't know i don't think i can find her
i find
[Applause]
i am but like the thing about yeah i'm
like on yeah like raya hinge a little
bit hit her up boys boys come on you
know what i mean you know i think
um but i think it honestly goes back
into like dating as like a curvier woman
too like i'll never play a victim and be
like it's so hard whatever but like
genuinely dating as a curvier like
thicker girl like
our body type sometimes gets overly
sexualized so like when i'm dating i
feel like i'm either being used to just
hook up or like i never even thought you
know what i mean like overly sexualized
so like for a guy to actually want to
make me his girlfriend i feel like i
don't like i just feel like they either
just want something from me oh so you
don't believe it yeah like i'm almost
like no you don't want to date me like
there's a right back there you want to
be with me but it's probably because
you've experienced that before yeah all
the time so i'm like
it makes sense for you to feel that way
yeah so what is it
because maybe we know a good guy that
won't sexualize yeah oh my god now i'm
getting nervous okay
what is my type um
it sucks but i usually like athletic
athletes okay
so like i don't always treat the best
and there's a stereotype behind them
right but i also like someone that's
like
very like driven and like passionate and
like works really hard like definitely
date an entrepreneur like a business guy
i love that ambition um super needs to
be like ambitious and wants to like
build with me
no
what's your oh god i was gonna ask you a
sign i can't do that why are you oh
fire it's area
that's how you say you're very like
sharp and you like it yeah yeah
yeah i'm just i'm like a burger so i
like love that too yeah yeah i think
it's so important to find someone though
that you want to push you like i feel
like that's like a really important
quality because a lot of people are like
yeah nice funny which is great yeah but
when it comes to like wanting a
relationship to progress and grow and be
better like you want someone that is
going to be almost like your partner in
crime to go hey baby like we're gonna
grow this we're gonna build this i want
you to go to that like go out of your
comfort zone and like you need that yeah
to like
better yourself it's hard to find today
though because i feel like guys are
almost scared if you're like
we're all in this uh trend of
hardballing right now which is basically
saying exactly what you want pretty
early on right waste your time yeah and
if you do want to put it out there being
like i want you know ambition and a guy
that we can like build a foundation
together they'd be like whoa whoa whoa
too much commitment too scary i mean
have you ever been on like a terrible
date like we love hearing bad dating
what was it one bad dating oh what do
you mean i met up with this oh here we
go
i met up with this producer guy he goes
let's get dinner i go great let me know
where we meet up to the restaurant you
guys no this homie
wearing sweatpants one yeah and not like
the cute gray sweats like sweatpants
like bummy slippers
like t-shirt i'm like all dressed up
heels jeans we're going like a nice
yes yes i swear to god i literally look
like you you're not bringing this in
right now like this is like the type of
people that like you know it's just yeah
i would never believe oh didn't order
dinner so what yeah so we sat there and
like i just got some drinks and i was
like this is literally the worst thing
in my life like and immediately let's go
back to this studio i was like i gotta
go like this
is what bothers me so much when i hear
stories like that
in the moment you're like i need to get
out and leave but then yeah i'm always
like too polite to do that same that's
my thing you're like why didn't i just
be like you know what it was yeah
i wish i could be that girl that was
like i don't like this i don't want that
and i'm out but like
my confidence with dating is like
i think in society we're always meant to
like please the guy make sure that the
guy's okay like checking in on the i'm
like [ __ ] that i wish i could be the
girl that would like stand up and be
like i'm out but i literally can't like
oh it's weird and i get lay we we are
very we're with our fashion trends and
we're always like we can like yeah look
i have a pair of sweats i can wear with
like boot heels and make it cool right
but like not for uh
i went to a really nice restaurant with
this guy once and he also showed up in
sweatpants and the bummy kind and i was
like
i'm in a full like tight body dress what
what is we're clash happening
are we going to mel's diner are we going
to tower bar like what is
like between there no i just i feel like
dating in la in general is just
impossible
it's like there's no one out there yeah
it's really hard you said that you were
good with um being confident like on
social media and yeah sort of being
online
does that mean you're confident in the
dms if you're going to slide in oh can
we like split into dm's like are you
good flirting on like text or
good at sliding in um
i would say okay like okay yeah but the
thing is that also sucks is that like i
would rather be like approached first
and like that could be like an ego thing
you know like me too you know like at a
bar i'm like [ __ ] he's so cute but like
i'm just gonna give him the eyes until
he comes over you know yeah
yeah that's me she's like she makes fun
of me because of that the eyes yeah
always in the eyes i just stare at them
and i realize i'm like i know they can
feel it oh yeah it's just an energy
thing yeah exactly like i don't have to
say anything and you'll just know i'm
down you know yep but if i'm staring at
you longer than three seconds like like
say i'm interested yeah like come over
thank you yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't
know
if you guys need to if it's more than
three seconds we're pulling you in
literally
it's like you're yeah 100
um so i would say i'm somewhat confident
like i definitely
i've yeah i've slid in a little bit been
somewhat successful somewhat right yeah
i feel like there's a 50 like 50 chance
right with everyone though yeah what do
you think you need to work on then for
dating wife because you were saying that
you feel because i know for me i
overthink every relationship like i'm so
i'm almost that person like i'm in a
relationship now but it takes me so long
to get to the point to admit that i like
someone or at least feel comfortable in
one like what do you think you need to
because i know her she almost she likes
to like get her whole emotion and it
we're actually opposite like
i'm so repressed until i get it and then
she's almost overly emotional and then
right much harder like what do you need
to do i would say like
i think i've been in so many toxic
relationships and like dating like the
worst guys that like i'm
i think that like if you come at me
super hard and heavy in the beginning
that like it's amazing oh my god this is
amazing i that's not normal like i've
started to realize that like every
relationship that goes off so strong in
the beginning like head over heels like
love bombing you know what love bombing
that's what it is
such a good point it's not and that's
what i struggle with yeah like what red
flags have you seen from dating toxic
people that you're like maybe people
should recognize like other than just
yeah because i know for me
it's when they're like obviously like
hiding their phone more or they won't
show you like dms or they want to
totally things like that like what have
you noticed
you know lots of those i know so seems
like you're like ready
um i only communicated them through
email
no
not email
and it was on do nothing
i know i know yeah
um when a guy shows too much affection
yeah it's sort of the same thing as
if you meet a girl yeah right off the
bat she's like you're my best friend my
best friend and you know how they give
like they act like you are already so
close when you guys just met and then
she ends up being the craziest person
you've ever met a hundred percent that's
the same i never thought about it
yes
like anything that what's the saying
it's like anything that like um goes too
quickly ends really quickly oh yeah and
so it's like i didn't realize that but
with friends too because i get close to
people quickly too which could be a fall
trait but i also feel like i just like i
don't know i feel like i'm just like
warm and like that's horrible
you know yeah but then i've noticed that
the girl like the friend or the guy that
i'm like oh my god like let's hang out
like let's get what are you doing
tonight like let's get drink does not
last like ever and so when a guy's not
putting in that crazy effort in the
beginning i'm like now trained to think
like he doesn't like me but really
that's probably normal it's totally not
like he's just busy and trying to figure
out who i am because how do you know if
you really like me if you don't even
know me right now i know i understand
the whole thing where people are like if
he's not 100 into you like it's not
worth it like i understand though the
slow burn you need a slow burn you need
it yeah to get to know each other right
now like game in the beginning is the
best i love the game i know you've seen
that in the games i believe in the games
i didn't get there a little bit a little
bit
like i'm not going to play monopoly with
you that's right it's complicated
checkers is good monopoly awesomeness
um let's talk about your youtube because
you are very vulnerable online well
first of all before we go on instagram
too i know you stopped youtube yeah well
it's more like tick tock now but yeah
yeah i did start youtube but when i did
peek on your channel the other day
oh god
i oh god no no it was good okay okay
okay i clicked on your audition for
sports illustrated oh
actually
did you see the recent one because i saw
both oh i saw that older i saw the
twenty-nine i said i saw the twenty she
saw all of them i loved it she was
auditioning
by the way
you are fulfilling the fantasy that
sophia and i have wanted to do for so
long yeah literally this year we were
like should we just
send in an audition for switzerland
i want you guys to no no but okay like
sister sister yes but i would just love
the package deal the process the mindset
of going into it like what really
sparked you to be like you know what i
want to be a part of this brand
i think like for so long now i think
going back to like my role model with
ashley graham seeing her on the cover in
2016. i was like okay
iconic like we could do this too like
because i've always wanted a model when
i was like a little kid my sister would
dress me up and take photos like i
always wanted to do it but then when i
got curvy i was like there's no shot
like [ __ ] this is not a career for you
like so why did you think that like why
did you think that because it's just you
just look in the media no career girl
was being shown if you were like a
little bit overweight it'd be like oh my
god she's so fat and the tabloids like
whatever i just didn't think yeah
because the media was pushing this like
narrative on us
skinny's beautiful and skinny's model
and that's it oh yeah and then it
started to change and i was like oh like
maybe i could do it and then i always
wanted si because i felt like they were
so inclusive and just a really great
brand that embodied like confidence and
hyping up woman like yeah where not a
lot of like editorials or magazines or
brands or companies like really um
appreciated that and like pushed for
that
so i was living in hawaii going to
school there and then i tried out in
2018 my first year wasn't a model like i
had no idea what i was doing like i
threw it out like horrible camera was
like shaky i had my friend take it like
horrible but good but like shot
i shot it in hawaii it was like the
worst way i've ever taken but it's so
cute to like look back on you know like
oh a little me like yeah like it's the
audition is quite interesting because
you're doing all of these b-roll shots
of you stunning in a bathing suit um i
remember your ass looked amazing thank
you but then i guess so like there's
voiceover happening you're like sort of
pitching yourself yeah so did your pitch
change from the first time that you
didn't get it and then what was the
difference do you think i think in the
beginning it was like i just want sports
illustrator like this would be so cool
like oh my god to be a model and like it
was more just like all over the place
yeah i think the next year was like oh
like you know i believe that like our
body type should be like shown and like
you know like represented i went to
miami did the whole casting call didn't
get it and then it wasn't until like the
final year 2020 when i was like okay now
like let's like get real let's get deep
like let's hone in on like what you want
and what's your message and i was like i
want to make a change like i don't just
want to like be a curvy girl on like a
mac because like by then like they've
been doing that like that's not
revolutionary like this is happening
yeah so like i wanted to stick out and
have like my own message of like like
honestly making change and also hyping
up that like
just like feeling beautiful in your skin
not feeling like you need to lose weight
but also like i was at a point in my
career at the time when i did the
audition where
i wasn't curvy enough so like i was
getting told no at jobs because i needed
to gain weight really and then yes and
then i was like wait what and they're
like oh because i was working out of
town they're like oh if you lose more
weight you lose your job like one girl
told me yeah so what's perfect it's like
exactly whatever it's impossible no and
you're fighting these like unrealistic
standards on both ends and then i'm sure
for like thinner models it's like if you
gain weight you lose your job you have
to be very thin but then on the other
spectrum it's like no keep gaining
weight and i'm like but that's not
healthy for me and like i like work out
all the time i played soccer for 15
years like i love to be athletic and
like you can't tell me that i have to go
gain weight like that's not healthy so
my message was more of like loving the
skin you're in and not having to change
for anyone and like you should be enough
you know so i think my message was like
really what hit this time yeah you know
so how was the whole process like when
you found out you got it what was that
call like
yeah they um you don't know for months
it's very like they're very secretive
they like to keep it on your toes it's
like literally torture patients um yeah
it was so hard i was like we're all just
texting group shots did you get a call
did you get a call like you know
um finally got a call and it was the
morning i was going to hawaii actually
which is so cool because it was like
going back to like where it all started
for me oh my gosh yeah it was like
really exciting and then got on the call
and they were like congratulations
finalists did it uh freaked out and then
in may we went and shot in atlantic city
because like covet we couldn't go like
overseas which kind of sucked but
um yeah it was like unbelievable it was
like a long journey though it was like
over a year oh like the whole
process yeah because that's amazing you
didn't quit yeah
i actually love you because when you
were just talking about what your
message was for this part of the casting
or why you got it this year because you
felt like you really honed it on exactly
what you wanted to articulate and your
instagram is fully that like i love that
you post like the same outfit in
different body types like it honestly is
like for even for me i'm like it shows
that there isn't like one ideal version
of beauty like you can be
any size look anyway and still be
beautiful in that outfit that you're
right like you're looking up to these
actresses i looked at the julia fox one
oh yeah yeah it's so [ __ ] cool in
there i was like okay she's killing it
and it was such a fun one it's so nice
because i know like we've we were in the
modelling and she was in a lot longer
than i've been in it yeah i know you've
been in it and you've probably had your
like horror stories
like yeah i remember even just for me
because i mean sistine's it was
different because like she's like very
petite so hers was like you're not thin
enough or you're not perfect that for me
it was you can literally ask her i would
be there because i'm like half
i don't know i'm like curvier they would
literally put like bags of clothes uh
like men's clothing on me just to hide
my body and like looking for i remember
in a fitting they would make you feel
horrible because you didn't fit in i
would say
exactly it's like then you knew who you
hired you knew my measurements
i remember there was that one huge brand
i really have photos on my phone and i'm
like i remember crying at the fittings
because i saw these beautiful dresses
i'm like i want these with the models
yeah like i want to be wearing that
stuff and they would find like the
biggest oversized jacket with the
longest skirt with boots and like a hat
and i'm like my i guess my body is ugly
so it's so nice that like you're showing
that that's yeah
so that's so [ __ ] wrong like that is
like not but it's so important for that
women like you are speaking out against
this because thank you i don't think
this would ever this endless cycle would
ever change or end if if girls like you
weren't advocating for the opposite
especially our bodies
but when it comes to female bodies it's
such a sensitive thing for us
and so anything that's negative on it is
so like even if you act as confident as
you are it still gets in your head and
it's still like that one experience or
if those you'll always remember that i
always remember like i'm confident now
about my body and i love it but i
definitely have those times where like
before we're going to an event tonight i
get in my head i'm like am i not that
enough am i not going to look in these
ways like were you did you ever have
those moments where you're like i had
that experience like now screw it like
i'm over this
yeah i think it's weird being on the
curvier side though because it's like
more um
appreciated to be thicker but so it's a
little bit different but like even
shooting with photographers sometimes
like knowing like oh that's the angle
when like of course that's the angle
because i'm sucking in my butt is that
and like it's like a great angle but
it's like that's literally
keep pushing that narrative like that's
the most attractive angle when you look
the thinnest and so it's like i'm
shooting and i don't even realize that
like what they're telling me is that
like yeah you look good in this photo
because you look the thinnest in that
photo right and so it's like people
don't realize it because like that's
what they were taught and that's what
they were so it's like it goes back to
like what we've been taught and like
what the media has told us but
it still messes with my head well it's a
weird line that you have to tear because
you want to make the client happy yeah
right you want to produce photos that
make them happy but at the other end of
it it's like is it even making me happy
right making me feel good do i feel good
exactly what was the most what do you
think because you probably have had like
a lot of people reach out to you being
like like you probably inspire me or
yeah i like love your content what has
been like probably the most frequent
thing you've gotten about your post like
or a question or maybe response
mainly just like so many girls opening
up about like you've helped me put on a
bikini for the first time i have like a
lot of moms actually that follow me that
are like
i haven't worn a tank top in eight years
because i hate my arms and i'm wearing a
tank top because of you like wow one
girl was like you're the reason why i'm
alive like i have a lot of people that
are like i yeah like deep [ __ ] i'm like
whoa and it's like
i want to be there for every single
person but that also takes so much
energy to sit and respond like you know
what i mean
i always want people to know that i see
that and i support that but it's almost
impossible to like reply to everyone um
but those are the main comments honestly
it's just like how confident they feel
now watching it and i think that's
what's cool is that like i don't even
need to like coach you on it like i
could just like make a fire video on
tick tock hype myself up feel myself in
the mirror and people are like oh my god
i feel so confident now it's like weird
it's like okay
i can do it yeah i mean it's incredible
to hear the feedback in such a positive
way that you're getting yeah your
content and i'm really excited for you
to sort of shift a little bit into the
confidence coaching
yeah what do you think the first thing
you're gonna do is or like the first
step are you gonna do more like
instagram lives or reels or how are you
gonna go about it i'm like super like
business savvy and very like
entrepreneur focused like aside from
modeling like i want to own multiple
companies like i'm like more
entrepreneur based so like i want to
start a company basically where like i'm
building out more of like a community
like i feel like growing up i never had
a community feel of like other girls
hyping each other up it's all [ __ ]
competition all the time so i want to
build a space of like maybe not
one-on-one client training but like
group like group client calls like and
just bring on people where like
basically like we're elevating our lives
and confidence and for sure and i've
actually never seen anything like that
because there's when you're feeling
just i don't know insecure about
yourself yeah it's just oh you should go
to therapy right but sometimes it's like
for me if i'm not feeling confident like
i don't need therapy i need someone to
reinforce or like reset my mind and go
really no this is why you need a little
tweak
like there's communities that went but i
feel like having a confidence coach or
having a confidence community where you
feel you can go to and just someone sell
you to you this is your body yeah you
have one life right i love it like this
is all you get just like that reminder
like always yeah and i feel like people
forget that they're like oh i need to
look no like this and everyone wants to
come out already right now i'll join i
know we are excited what's next
coming up um that's in the works for
sure um i really liked like the julia
fox shoe and just like recreating those
looks so i'm gonna try to figure out a
way that i can start doing more of those
100
um continuously like just like trying to
reach out to agencies and try to get
signed because right now i'm in miami
but i am not in la right now
that's a whole different story are you
living in my uh no i'm living in l.a but
i don't have an agent here so i'm like
in the process of finding one um
just continuing like partnering with
brands and like trying to just figure
out my way in it i mean this is all
still new for me like i love it thanks
is there like one quote you always
follow or one thing you always follow
that has been kind of like your motto
for what you stand for or something that
you kind of remind yourself that you
love you're like this is something that
like hones in for me yeah i mean it says
it sounds cliche but i always say like
there's one you in this world and that
is your power and i think it's so true
because it's like you literally could
feel like [ __ ] like like one day but if
you remember like literally no one else
on this earth is you like that's [ __ ]
cool like no one is you and no one is
you and no one is any of us like we
carry something so unique and special
and like even on your worst days if you
can like remind yourself that you're
like oh yeah [ __ ] i am that [ __ ] like
there's only one me like you know
exactly and it's like keep reminding
yourself that because you are unique
like it's i just think that's like the
coolest part my truck
[Applause]
this was a conversation that i needed to
hear today
yeah they're so amazing i love you so
much thank you please tell everyone
where they can find all of your your
social medias yeah instagram everything
um follow me at ella lucas at um tick
tock and instagram and i'll be coming
out with some confidence courses soon so
stay tuned
um confidence queens and kings let's get
it go out there be confident we love you
guys and we'll see you next tuesday bye
[Music]